so rhenium is a fairly modern element it
was early discovered in that I think the
ninth about 1925 so it's 80 odd years
old your grandparents could be older
than rhenium at least the discovery of
rhenium it is now becoming increasingly
important particularly in the
manufacture of aircraft engines as you
probably know in the aircraft engine you
have these huge blades that whiz round
and round and because engines are going
faster and faster and higher and higher
temperature they need to be stronger and
stronger and rhenium is now an
ingredient that you can put or that can
be put into the metal making the blades
that makes them behave more effectively
at high temperature and this is almost
leading to world shortage of rhenium so
this is a sample of rhenium okay this is
a very very nice metal often used in
catalysis from the middle of the
transition metal group and here you see
a very very dark black coloration of
this very very fine wire of rhenium the
chemistry rhenium is also interesting
and unlike technetium radium is not
highly radioactive materials so that
chemists can easily study it there
interesting reactions of rhenium which
will under the influence of light turn
carbon dioxide which is a very inert
waste material can actually be activated
and made to react to make something more
useful and also that there are other
reactions of rhenium which I think will
become more important in the future